sembra che questo bellissimo video la
postazione e questo or the school
postazione by fa vj se potete vedere
tutto il mio sfondo nella sua
magnificenza perché sto ancora
aspettando che va da fornire idea la
nuova casa i mister mi stanno ancora
facendo per adesso sto ancora un pò qua
e registro un po di video direttamente
la nostra che non penso vi dispiaccia
se notate i ragazzi su fall guys
el'aborto che non ci gioco ma almeno ros
isola dobbiamo provare a guardandoti la
skin che ciò quale il gatto ancora
incredibile pensate se avessero messo
sti update subito dopo la prima season
che quanta gente avrebbe ancora giocato
a folgaria invece li dovete mettere pian
piano ragazza la partenza è stranissima
non so niente ci provo perché non so
neanche il kodak cos'è santo iddio non
stop non so neanche capendo cosa succede
ok ok non ci sono dei mondi che mi
colpiscono va bene ce l'ho fatta
perfetto non saprei neanche spiegare
cosa ho fatto però vabbè questo un
flipper
ok porca vacca ragazzo è bellissimo è
veramente la cosa mi sembra l'update più
belle ecco niente sto dicendo mi sembra
l'update più bello visto gioco da quando
ci gioco è veramente bellissimo
però devo arrivare devo arrivare ragazzi
sono stati questi apparecchi scottano ma
non ti fanno niente ok
mamma mia che ansia ma cos'è no vabbè ma
solo sto livello vari tutto sono suo
livello vale tutto tutto vale a ti fa
vedere chi arriva i traguardi adesso
bellissimo e due ragazzi domanda cosa
devo fare ad e mandarli minchia non si
capiva no va bene va no vabbè ragazzi
diventati incredibile ma da quando è che
cambiata la season se posso chiedere
cioè nasce da quanto c'è porca vacca non
riesco ad arrivare o che ci ho fatto
cose che fanno questi scusami a puoi
scegliere la strada se andare sopra il
flipper può sembrare guarda molto casto
livello è un ora e mezza di livello già
incredibile fatto benissimo
lo so che mi sto rimettendo la sola
veramente emozionato è fatto
è il livello più bello che abbia giocato
da quando il giorno sto gioco bellissimo
abbiamo ancora quante scheme muove 40 40
five mening cos'è sta roba è una sorta
di mix tra rollout si chiamavano l'amico
ecco gli altri con gli ostacoli è un mix
di cose vediamo che figata
per ora tutto bene ragazzo sto capendo
nulla di quello che sto facendo ma vado
allora ragazzi cielo lo scalino e
bastardo è lo scarica basta in me di
trancoso e l'altro lo scalino non ci
vuole perché chi depista ma poi cerca di
buoni cioè finita oppure no no no non lo
so cosa succede se c'è il check point
che sono cagato nelle mutande se vi
interessa saperlo lo so che non mi
interessava me lo dico ok ce l'ho fatta
e stato veramente difficile però bokeh
ok ma tanta roba
come molti di 20 nuovi o il buon vecchio
tipton questo va bè questo conosciamo
lega allora ragazzi vediamo se riesco ad
arrivare alla fine da sguardi butto
subito sulla scia giusta avatar
celo celo hai visto la sentivo è braille
breve lo abbiamo perso
troppa troppa gente invece no
ancora ancora ci sono posti allora
ragazzi next up abbiamo il semifinale la
semifinale teoricamente anno fa il round
si odano ok giorgio l'aula conosciamo
abbiamo fatto diversamente le prime due
poi per il resto è abbastanza uguali
jobs showdown ragazzi per oggi migliori
se riusciamo a fare una roba finale
decente poi magari non vinco ma almeno
la gioco al cento per cento le mie
capacità nettop e una bianca quando fa
rinviare all'acqua che ci questi
pacchetti con
uno scienziato ma cos'è che bella star
skinner è bellissima ma dopo mi sono
salvato riportarli in live ogni tanto
capita che da un po che non ci gioco per
per il calo di manutenzione let's go
ottimo mancano tantissime persone per la
pensiamo in abbiamo due piattaforme
vicine quindi ok è la cosa che
preferisco perché almeno in te stesso
che vuoi tempi raga 4 ore mining ciao 5
no non so cosa sia successo qualcuno mi
ha tenuto feo qualcuno mi ha tenuto ha
sbattuto contro qualcosa non so vabbè mi
piace un sacco sto coso che questi salti
molto più in alto è bellissimo c'è genia
poi il primo salto è gigantesco nove
ragazzi studiata da dio allora meglio di
non cadere 8 volte su sti mondi come dal
perfetto
la partenza stavolta incredibile ragazzo
ok bestie non ho capito cosa sono in
programma a lanciano stelle va bene a
per colpire gli altri all'altra parte
nostro male ma cosa si sono studiati
lager
va bene attraverso tutto ok e ragga
parlare solo a questi così cambiano
portali c'è ma sta roba
il genio cacchio aprite questo a
stappare gira ok perché gira gira gira
di rafer fetto sono quasi primo non so
come quando si capisce una sega ha posto
flip è arrivato tra i primi e quindi
ottimo è certo però questa volta dovrà
esserci è lo sapevo che perde un sacco
di tempo qua ma voglio farlo è più forte
di me bisogna andare piano piano
tanto non volevo arrivare alla fine io
volevo farlo pian piano parsimonioso e
non sono riuscito comunque pensate
dove devo farmi sparare a lato ma non mi
spara lato mi spara nel mezzo o due ore
ce l'ha fatta per miracolo per la mia
testardaggine castro faccio l'ha fatta
per miracolo perché alla fine si è
arrivati
mamma mia in testa che frigge male ma se
il mio compagno perché sapeva che ero
bravo valle cosa gli altri la marea
rubata subire
e allora ragazzi problema è mio e che la
mia squadra non sta prendendo troppi
troppe cose quindi di aiuto ecco la
verità non ha preso non so come
mannaggia io vado nel ormai la tattica
che usavo spesso era andare nel mezzo
perché nel mezzo in genere nessuno viene
invece adesso a noi c'era che si è
sviluppata st tecnica tutti vanno nel
mezzo adesso e fate caso c2 pieno di
gente nel mezzo occhio mi è cascato
addosso il culo chiedeva qualcosa ma
dove ma chi
ma scusa al 98 dove può fargli sputare
scusami studi nenie terzo aperto bocca
sono venuto a rubare un mio caso non
l'ho fatto al mio compagno vabbè 33
ragazzi le scrivo
ora che abbiamo fatto le mappe vecchie
spero che esca roba nuova verso le
finali visto che non ho visto nulla
eccola skyforger skype o l'avevano già
fatta però è bella ed è di un ansioso
che non avete idea frigi waba manas non
sei scappare ma non il fatto che
installa padri centrali cui non cambia
niente arrivare alla fine quindi cosa
serve prendere sti cosi per prendere il
centro si vabbè molto bene qualcuno è
già arrivato se gioco e c'è gente che si
è già qualificata che fanno a perché il
finale vanno un sacco di punti vero
niente non riuscirò mai a prendere
finale se non prendo con le molle non
sono contento ok devo buttarmi sul
finale teoricamente che se no non ci
arrivo ok
ok niente ma no che non l'ho presa molla
ma va a cagare che schifo se riuscita
accade nelle punto più brutto non ce
l'ho perso io penso perché ne mancano 5
qualificati ma c'è da due qualificati
volevo dire ci ho provato ragazzi ci ho
provato è stato ed è un peccato fra le
mappe e 9 sono bellissime era un po che
non perdevo così indietro e pro ci sta
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto lo
sarà for guys die today fatemi sapere se
volete altri episodi io rifarei perché
magari sono uscite mappe 9 che hanno
ancora fatto quasi andare a simili a
piacere e mi piace anche lei sto
cercando descrizione sociale fischietti
e noi come sempre ci vediamo a un
prossimo video delle ragazze
[Musica]